[Music]
so I was on the way to the office this
morning
and I realized it is very much like web
day rush hour okay rush hour like yes
traffic right everybody trying to get to
the office 9:00 a.m. right so yeah all
these people in their cars
I've got trains everything everyone's
just like rushing and nobody can move
for anybody else and I think that's like
web because we've lost please explain
this a bit more yes because you've got
the main thread you've got this one
thread and on that main thread you've
got all this work styles JavaScript
layout paint composite your friends
everything is running and everybody's
competing for this one resource the road
or in this case the main threads so like
mr. mr. framework has a car mr. paint
has a car mr. business logic has a car
and they're all just wanted on the row
but it's already fall exactly and
everybody's in the same boat where I
really gets the angry tweets and sees
kind of all this performance advice and
nobody knows what to do because all this
stuff is just constrained into this one
place rush hour as we described in that
video that's kind of how we feel when we
look at the web large we look at it we
go it all these codes should be here but
it just feels like the traffic is the
problem like there's just too much going
through the main thread and
traditionally you would you know the
main thread is fall it's overworked and
underpaid you would say cool iight use
threads on any other platform you could
do that just spin up a thread put some
code there run it there call a function
alright everyone's happy but turns out
javascript and the web is special and it
is inherently single threaded so you
can't do that right exactly it's every
thread is kind of this its own little
universe isn't it like was there we
heard it's a v8 I slit right yeah and so
you can't just go just call this on
another thread but you've got some
shared stuff that you can work on so
that's a challenge and then it gets more
interesting because say for example
you're trying to build I don't know like
a chess game just for argument's sake
and you've got a chess engine and the
chess engine it is it takes a few
hundred milliseconds to calculate to
move I know more I mean it gets
exponentially practical and you build it
with DOM and then some bright spark goes
you know what we should do 3d and you're
like I was already I was already behind
on my Perth budget if you could just not
do the 64
the second thing that would be great and
some even brighter Spock says how about
VR yeah I want to stand on the chess
board yeah I want to be like right in
the game and you're thinking there was
already rush hour points out framerate
quite important when it comes to VLR
yeah and it could be voice there's so
many things that it could be so this
comes increasingly unlikely to for you
to be able to do this successfully on
the web currently right and so this is
the question that we have been thinking
through for the last little while is
there anything we can do anything we can
suggest think of to help we have two
birds we're looking for stone exactly
and well okay wow I really need to think
I was gonna say next
okay yes so we kind of stumbled over
this the actor model is as it says right
here about 45 years old and it's been
used in or made popular by Erlang and
then continues with elixir and ponies
there it's languages that use the actor
model to this day and successfully so
and we cannot realize that it's actually
a really good fit for the web yeah
because what it does is it kind of it
makes a feature of that single-threaded
nosara script but we like to exploit if
you come across it before great if
you've not come across the actor model
we like to explain it in a very specific
way so take check this one out so when
we did supercharged you saw us on screen
but behind the cameras we had an entire
crew and that means we had one person
working the camera we had one person
worrying about that our audio was good
we had a director and each of these
people was solely responsible for that
specific device and instead of going
over and pressing one person's buttons
or or just messing with settings those
people actually have to communicate with
one another to get the job done if you
like their actors in the system where
they've got to send messages to one
another and communicate and collaborate
in order to get the final thing working
so that's kind of where more video more
production value is good right so that's
where we kind of see a mentality that
fits the web really well and you start
thinking about where can you draw a line
for in the
Vigil pieces of responsibility in your
app and instead of thinking about
classes and how you call the method on
the other class you can now think about
these actors and how you can send the
right message to request something to
happen right this is like this areas of
ownership so let's think about how at a
conceptual level like how would you
think this through
or would it look like a little bit okay
so imagine you have an actor and its job
is to run your user interface that's its
area of ownership that's what it does
that's its job and only that you might
also have another actor whose job it is
is the handle state for your application
and yet another one who handles the
storage now imagine in your app typical
interaction will be something like
favoriting an item the user interface
when the user taps on it will send a
message over to the state that says this
was favorited in turn the actor handling
the state will send a message to the
storage to say we need to remember that
they favorited this item now we could
also at this point introduce a new actor
into this story something that could
broadcast because when the state changes
typically what we'd want to do is we'd
want to send that both the user
interface and the storage to be
reflecting it to be reflected in both I
suppose really yes and so you can kind
of see here that really is a separation
of concerns how the click there go
animal transition do you recommend
oh yeah it really helps you to think
about your app in a different way
helping you to figure out where does new
code go which module can you switch out
to fix a problem that you're having it's
a really good way to structure your app
in this way yeah absolutely we're used
to separation of concerns when we talk
about HTML Javascript and CSS or when we
talk about components in a modern
framework so it's another version of
that same story I suppose another
benefit that you get and we have heard
about this problem a couple of times
think yesterday and today is that we
often see big chunks of analytic
JavaScript just run frameworks updating
the virtual DOM and then the Dom or
something like that and with its pattern
you introduce a natural breaking point
where you give the browser a chance to
ship a frame because every time you send
a message that kind of is a point we say
ok browse I can intervene and ship a
frame if we are out
budget exactly now a little sort of side
effect positive one of this is location
independence and we'll come back to this
is sort of repeating refrain that we're
going to get into a little bit more but
think about actors as they're not all
the same
they have different requirements some
actors will not need to have access to
the main thread for example because of
the kind of work they do and as such we
might be able to run them in different
locations ie not on the main thread as I
say we'll come back to that but the idea
here is maybe we just bought ourselves a
little capacity for rush hour because as
long as the messages get delivered to
the actor the actor will then do the
same work a bit before and will respond
with the same message so the entire app
keeps behaving the same way no matter
what runs and because of that location
of location independence we can lower
the likelihood of long work impacting
the main thread and making your app
janky exactly so conceptually that's
what it is but I think I maybe just does
but I like seeing code I think code
helps so we have we're not launching a
product we're not launching a framework
or even a library we just want to have a
chat with you about architectures and
we've been using some active base stuff
for the last little while with our
colleague Tim and the three of us have
just been putting some code together so
what we're going to do is were going to
just show you a little bit of the code
that we've been using we've been using
it to build some of our apps and we'll
share that at the end
yes very welcome to try it out welcome
to write your own we don't really care
if you use our version of someone else's
version get more about the concept about
the architecture absolutely so but with
this in mind let's talk about a
particular up something like a a
stopwatch app which you'd substantive in
seconds pause play that kind thing and
then you might reset the time if you're
done so in our code we have this actor
base class and that top function up
there hook up is the first thing that
you'd need to know and the job of hook
up is the kind of register and actor in
the system so that we can talk to it
later so we can send it messages later
on because ultimately we won't know
where this actor is in the system and so
we just need a I was like a registry I
suppose
where we can say I'm going to tell you
there's an actor and it's found under
this name it's basically the equivalent
of what you might know from custom
elements there's custom elements that
define and you say this custom element
is now known under this name and this
does the exact same thing but for actors
cool so then we have our two actors
o'clock one and the UI one and then in
the bootstrap we instantiate both UI and
hook it up so it's available under UI as
a string name and then we do the same
with the clock like so so now we can
talk about how you might implement
something like the clock itself and in
our case when you've got something like
this it's a almost like a pure data
actor it doesn't have any need to go
near the Dom it just wants to tick and
pause and all those kinds I mean what do
you need you need you need a set
interval and that's pretty much it
it's a time out sure I have a thing
against say interval it's a long story
come find me afterwards I'll explain why
anyway imagine this then we're going to
model this as a state machine what an
idea we start with a paused state our
clock is paused we can transition to a
running state every second will tick and
we'll go to the tick state and that will
take us back to the running state and
you can imagine being in this kind of
tick running tick running state like an
o'clock like ping pop like a clock
indeed we could pause and we could reset
and when we reset we go back to that and
that's a really nice pattern here that
plays along well with a message passing
off the actor model because all of these
triggers as they're called in the state
machine world could just be a message
you sent a message to this state machine
it's being ingested and then a
transition happens absolutely so so we
found actually that there's a lot of
implementations for state machines out
there in the wild and that's not very
unexpected and we have kind of been
using X state which is written by David
from Microsoft and it's working really
well it allows you to declare your state
machine as adjacent objects as to Claire
States and then what the transitions are
and then you kind of just pass this to
the this machine constructor and you get
a state machine yeah so our clock
extends the actor base class and what we
do is we instantiate our state machine
we say go to the initial state which
happens to be that paused
and then later on imagine that we
receive a message and our actor based
class has this on message callback which
is I got a message what do I do in this
case we would assume that the state
would be changing inside of our state
machine so we use the state machine
transition to get from wherever it was
to wherever it needs to be so the
message is basically driving the clock
and we'll inspect what the new state
value is so if we find that our clock is
running we'll set a tick timeout for one
second if we tick we increment our tick
count and then the clock will send
itself a message
now it could call its own functions but
we tend to be a little bit we like it
fair and so what we do is we make sure
the clock sends itself a message like
every other actor would have to send it
a message you can have added like a
message queue that buffers all the
message and the actor goes through one
message processes then goes to the next
message and so if you just call your own
function you would kind of be cutting
that line so if you want to keep it fair
you will just queue your app and message
at the end and wait like a good human
exactly or a computer sure
cancel the tick if you're paused if
there's one pending when we reset we'll
reset the ticket count and again send
the hook will send itself a message to
pause and now let's talk about Ono
talked about sending messages that's
next yes so the clock who's going to
have to send a state update to the user
interface so that it can reflect you
know the time going up and so and so on
and so forth and this is the opposite to
the hook up this is lookup which is also
in about double hook up hook up look up
alright I'll leave him for hours at a
time when he does this so okay hook up
and look up so we look up the UI and
then we can send it a message and that's
very important to note you the handle
this UI variable we have there it is not
the act or instance you can't go in and
change a member variable of a class it
is just an object with the sent methods
and only that method because that's the
only way you're allowed to interact with
any of the other actors exactly and so
in this case we're gonna send the UI a
message and the message is going to say
what the time is and whether or not the
clock is running
we found that typescript is really
helpful at this point because those
messages need to be well formed and well
understood and there needs to be a data
con
correct and we've just found from
practical experience that typescript is
a really good way of saying this object
looks like this this is a number this is
a string this is another object and so
on and so forth so just take that as
what it is really we're in final yeah
recommendation we found that useful
let's talk about the UI a little bit
interestingly you can bring your own
framework yeah in this model you don't
we don't really care what kind of
framework you use you can use react you
can use view you can use lit you can use
swell whatever you feel comfortable with
or whatever make sense in your scenario
the interesting shift here is that the
UI framework is not your basic platform
out your entry point anymore the center
of the universe has kind of moved yes
that bootstrap that we showed you I is
just one participant of many in the
system of actors and if you find that
it's not behaving well for whatever
reason you can swap it out the only
thing it has to do is listen to messages
of a particular type which is kind of
cool in our case though we're going to
use pre-act works just great so we're
going to import pre-act UI extends the
active class and when it receives a
message we're gonna have it render using
pre-act to the in this case the document
body same again here we need to send
messages back absolutely and to do that
it is a case of the on the UI side we
find our clock actor who do a look-up on
it and we will send it a message in this
case for this particular example sending
it a message to start but there we want
for stop or reset and so on now we get
to talk about that location independence
a teeny bit more because one of the
questions that Surma Tim and I asked
ourselves when we were making our actors
is does this actor need access to the
main thread and this is kind of to do
with the rush hour thing our general
rule of thumb and there are some caveats
we'll mention in a moment but that
general rule of thumb is that the UI
actor is the one that really needs the
Dom and therefore it's the one that
ought to be on the main thread wherever
possible there's an exception the
exception here is that certain API slows
for media security device capabilities
and identity are only available on the
main thread today we think it's a bug
and we've been talking some chrome
engineers about exposing these kind of
API sinner worker
and somewhere else but that's just not
the world we live in today so
now that's a restriction yeah and tools
not rules so you might be thinking ah I
should move all my actors away from the
main threat we'll get to that but the
thing is if you've got a really chatty
actor that needs to talk to the UI actor
you might want to leave it alongside the
UI act on the method because as Jason is
should we were talking about earlier
there's a cost to the thread hop and
that might be more expensive than just
sending a message and just keeping the
actor alongside the UI actor okay so
basically if you want to do that just
measure and see what the impact is
exactly so the location independence so
all that notwithstanding imagine we were
back here where we started with our four
actors and they're all on the main
thread which is probably where we'd put
them by default we're sort of saying you
might want to look at it more like this
and you might be thinking why do they
say not main thread surely they just
meant web workers and we kind of did
because in in most cases when we build
these apps yet web workers do feature
heavily we do move quite a lot of our
actors to web workers especially if
they're non chatty but not quite so we
actually think or have tried that it's
sometimes very very useful to run an
actor for example on the server side and
that is kind of an interesting jump to
make because it allows you to
incorporate your back-end into the
architecture of your entire app it is
just another actor in the system and as
a matter of fact the game that you've
been playing all day and it totally had
no bucket at all whatsoever
is actually written in this model so
every player that is playing is an actor
the admin panel that the MCS used to
control the app is an actor the
presentation view just another actor and
then the firebase stored and shared
actor that's running on the server side
now interestingly the the mechanism by
which they chat using the hook-up and
lookup can be anything could be fetch it
could be a WebSocket and it really
doesn't matter it's layer based database
yeah so long as they can talk these
actors can talk and they've got a way of
sending messages to one another you're
all set so back to our original question
did we actually help with rush hour
would this actually help well let's
review so
one thing that we definitely did achieve
is that we are kind of making it less
likely to have big chunks of
uninterruptible JavaScript and more
little chunks where the browser can stop
it in between and ship a frame so that's
definitely one advantage that we have
the location independence hopefully some
of our actors can be run successfully
away from the main thread hopefully it's
like fewer cars on the road at rush hour
that's good for everybody typically and
as a result a lot of work that can
happen in an unexpected way if you're
processing a big API response something
that can happen in the worker and not
affect your main thread from going into
jank mode there are some other benefits
that
Surma Tim and I have noticed as well
working in this particular pattern one
is better testing with that kind of area
of ownership it's very it's easier not
was very easy but it's easier to look at
an act and go well I know what you
should do and you've got an on-message
that I can call and I can make sure that
you do the right thing so the testing
seems to become a little bit easier yeah
from the other side you can mock another
actor by just implementing the messages
that that actually is to receive and not
do the actual work but just send
pre-recorded messages back you get the
clear separation of concerns which again
it's just a it helps it it helps you in
terms of maybe dividing the work with
your teammates or even just deciding for
yourself you know which actor needs to
be responsible for this part of the
system and you get the code splitting
because we have actors that can be
hooked up to the system at any point in
time really it allows you to split them
up and load them lazily
you can just import them when you need
them yep that's good yeah and bring your
own framework if you want to use a
particular library or framework you can
this is it's not that you have to
there's not a prescriptive way if you
want to use some one thing use it great
now there are some considerations in
this world in this setup that we've
described one is active performance
challenges if you imagine your UI actor
imagine it decides to run long and just
be not very yield II you still have that
problem it's no different to a process
or an application in an operating system
deciding it's going to hug the CPU right
I mean this is this is not going to go
away but we do think that the scheduler
API the jason and should be mentioned in
the previous talk is a huge part of this
story because it's a great way for
individual actors to start breaking
their work up into smaller chunks you
may also be sitting there going I'm not
sure I could actor eyes my blog and we
would agree it's not necessarily for all
use cases this works really well when
you've got apps and in particular apps
where you think actually yet I can I can
ring-fence I can mark off particular
parts of this application and I can have
some kind of owner for it that's where
it works really well and there is
definitely a different mental model to
this as I said there it kind of shifts
the center of the universe away from the
UI framework into many center pieces all
the actors just communicating so it
definitely took us a time to build an
intuition for where do we draw the line
what becomes an act or what is just part
of an already existing actor what kind
of messages should we send how granular
should this entire set up be so if it
seems weird at first if you're playing
around with this that is parrot really
expect it's a very different way of
architecture in a web app so that was
the rush hour bit that future facing
stuff like the VRA are and so on well we
have some thoughts there to watch this
so you were talking about actors before
and I want to talk about cameras and the
reason I want talk about cameras is
because it all plays into that story
right so if you think one of these
lenses to be able I drop it because I
don't want it you monitor your modern
camera has two bits the camera body
which is the thing that kind of holds
the state whether you're shooting in
JPEG or Raw when you guys like the
business logic it's going to take the
picture and how to store it and does all
that yep
whether you're shooting video or taking
photos whether you are autofocus manual
focus do you get the idea
similar to like a web app right that's
the sort of the state of what's going on
but you've got different lenses for
different tasks so that one would be
something like portrait lens yeah this
one might be a wide-angle take something
of a landscape yeah so we make sure that
the mounds are compatible which I guess
in active work means that they speak
with the same messages to each other yes
so the messages that they sent are
really important they're sort of
standardized right
and everybody kind of plays to that same
data contract other than that you can do
what you like plug it in off you go last
video I promise yeah so camera lenses
why camera lenses how does that apply to
this story when we talked about this
earlier I think very naturally we would
have all thought of the Dom we'd have
thought of in the chess game we'd have
thought of this version but there's the
freedom that you get from a UI actor
that it can as long as it can speak the
right messages it can be implemented in
different technologies so you could have
a different actor that does 3d and now
you get that it just has to send the
same messages as the Dom version the
standard Dom version or maybe one 4xr
similarly it needs to be able to do that
send the right messages and perhaps
something like voice as well similar
kind of story so it's a byproduct of the
actor model we've all of a sudden got
these different swappable UI actors that
we can take with us wherever we need to
go and you might say well actually all I
need in this particular app is the XR
and voice or maybe I want Dom and voice
and you could even imagine a setup where
you have a Dom actor with lots of
effects and visuals and one Dom actor
implements the same app but with a much
less intense memory consumption version
like a low low-end version of your
website yeah and once you detect that
the device we're running on is actually
kind of struggling to keep up you can
actually switch it out in the middle of
the app and downgrade to the lower
visual version yeah or one we say
reduced motion or something like that
and technically this will be called
multi view or multi modal which is a
very fancy way of saying there's lots of
ways to interact with your web app and
as a vibrant
within the actor model enables you to do
that pretty well so if you're interested
in looking at the hook up and look up in
the actor base class that we mentioned
earlier this would be the place to go if
you want to take this now for that this
is actually not only the actor bass
class but it's actually a boiler plate
so it gets you started there it's roll
up configured where you can just build
it does the code splitting the lazy
loading it should get you started really
quickly so you can start writing actors
and get a feel for how it feels let's be
clear I mean it's experimental it's just
the stomping ground that we've been
using for the last little while and we'd
love you to take a look and have a chat
with us and just tell us what you think
so in summary we're actually quite
excited that something from 45 years ago
has kind of come full circle and is
which it seems to be you know the thing
that residing in plain sight yeah and
it's you know it's some from some other
places in computing we've kind of
brought it over not in a purist way we
have our own take on these things but it
respects that single thread enos of
JavaScript it seems to help with
rush-hour and it also seems to enable us
to go multimodal which is really kind of
exciting and on that note thanks thank
you very much
[Music]